foreign
so you're the CEO of a publicly traded
company and you want to make more money
and let's say your company is not a sexy
company like Tesla or something like
that but more of a boring Bland company
like waste management for example I'm in
a waste management business the trash
company with those iconic dark green
trash trucks I'm the trash man and as
the CEO of a company like this the only
way you can make more money is by
pumping the company's stock price to the
Moon why because when the stock price
goes up investors are happy the board is
happy which means you get a higher
salary you'll get paid more bonuses a
lot of your money comes from stock
options where you get to buy stock at a
set price which means the higher you
pump the stock price the more money you
send to make if the stock price keeps
growing the board of directors will want
to keep you round instead of firing and
replacing you and a ton of other reasons
that is why Executives of public
companies are obsessed with getting
their stock price as high as possible it
is the air they breathe is how they get
wealthy so we have to do everything in
our power to get that number up and
there are a few ways to increase your
stock price number one you could just
build a better more profitable company
this is by far the best way but as you
can imagine building a great company
reducing expenses increasing profits
constantly innovating and sustaining
that growth over years and years and
years is really really really hard we
need to find an easier faster way which
brings us to the number two instead of
building a better company you could just
have The Narrative of a revolutionary
disruptive Tech startup set to change
the world when you have The Narrative of
a Tesla you can Skyrocket your stock
price while your company is actually not
making any money but again you're a
trash collecting company so unless you
want to venture into self-driving trash
trucks or something this really isn't an
option so that only leaves us with
option three instead of actually
building a better company that justifies
a higher stock price or instead of
building up a bunch of hype as a tech
company you can just make your company
look like it's doing insanely well on
paper without doing any of the actual
hard work this is also known as cooking
the books now hear me out here the board
of directors analysts and big investors
typically judge a public company on only
one thing
profit profit ah yes the mighty bottom
line that is the only thing anyone ever
looks at once left over after all the
money you made and spent and the great
thing about your books is that you can
easily cook them change a few numbers
here change a few numbers there and all
of a sudden you take a mediocre company
and make it look like a revolutionary
one that I have to buy shares of right
now before it climbs any higher just to
be clear cooking the books is fraud and
I don't actually recommend you doing it
but that is exactly what Waste
Management did see collecting trash is
not a very exciting business there's not
exactly a lot of room for insane growth
and the CEO of waste management at the
time Dean bun truck was well aware of
this he has spent the last few decades
buying up the entire trash industry in
America which made Waste Management look
amazing they were experiencing all this
growth and became a darling on Wall
Street waste management was a safe bet
everyone needs their trash taken out and
look how fast they're growing but it got
to the point where there is simply no
other competitors to buyouts Dean had
reached a glass ceiling and if he didn't
do something Waste Management would
stagnate and their stock price would
come crumbling down but Dean still
wanted more money he still wanted more
bonuses he needed his stock options to
be worth tens of millions of dollars so
he systematically cooked the books for
years and it worked in early 1992 the
stock was at around 17 just six years
later it was a staggering 55 dollars for
a trash company
and as a result him and his top
Executives made off with tens of
millions of dollars all thanks to this
fraud and this is a master class on how
he pulled it off stay dangerous and
let's get into it
[Music]
[Applause]
have you noticed that a lot of sponsored
spots on YouTube lately are for emo
newsletters like morning Brew or how
every YouTuber tries to launch their own
newsletters it's because newsletters can
make a lot of money think about it
morning brew has over 4 million
subscribers 4 million eyeballs and every
single email they send out contains
sponsor spots Brands will pay a lot of
money to get featured in giant
newsletters like these that's why
morningbrew was able to make over 50
million dollars in Revenue in 2021 alone
all from running a short email every day
it is insane that's why if you're
looking to start your own side hustle
you should consider this emo newsletter
business model you know how to be on
camera or edit videos all you have to do
is write emails people want to read and
the sponsor money will come and the best
platform to create your newsletter is
called send Fox stemfox allows complete
beginners to launch your email list
without breaking the bank you can use it
to build landing pages and forms to
collect emails without needing any
design skills and then you can use their
easy to use tools to to create engaging
email campaigns with custom colors text
images that look just as good as the
most successful newsletters out there
and what's really cool is that if you
can't think of what to write you can use
their smart campaigns feature which will
pull content from your social accounts
like your Twitter Instagram or podcast
and then automatically repurpose that
existing content into new emails with
just one click so you don't even have to
write a thing typically software like
this requires a monthly subscription but
thanks to our friends at appsumo you can
get lifetime access to sunfox for just
49 with the link below no recurring
subscription and you get a 60-day
money-back guarantee so you can try out
launching your newsletter and if you
don't like it you're not out of any
money so what are you waiting for
launcher newsletter business right now
with send Fox for just 49 with the link
below thanks to appsumo for sponsoring
this video
[Music]
so cooking the books
see as a trash company you have to spend
a lot of money on equipment like trash
trucks these trash trucks cost a lot of
money today they cost around three
hundred thousand dollars each which cuts
into your profits since you have to buy
a ton of trash trucks every year but
there's a little trick we can play to
make us look more profitable on paper
see when you buy a piece of equipment
like a trash truck you can transfer your
cash into this thing you can still sell
the trash truck and get cash back so
technically you're not out of three
hundred thousand dollars entirely you
just transferred that three hundred
thousand dollars of value from cash into
the thing and every year as you use this
truck the resale value of it goes down
so instead of showing the entire three
hundred thousand dollar loss this year
thanks to this trash truck the
government lets you break this loss up
over a few years with something called
depreciation
in the case of Waste Management they
were able to break up the depreciation
of their trash trucks over eight years
so to keep this simple that means if a
truck costs you three hundred thousand
dollars every year you can depreciate
around thirty seven thousand five
hundred dollars of that 300K for the
next eight years so every year you spend
around thirty seven thousand five
hundred dollars from the trash truck
going down in value Waste Management has
over 32 000 trash trucks so every year
in this example they're showing a
staggering 1.2 billion dollar loss on
their books just from this depreciation
thing that is not good we gotta start
cutting the crust off this sandwich if
we want the company to look more
profitable on paper we need to do
something about this depreciation thing
so in the case of Waste Management the
goal for them was to bring on new
investors in the way you bring on new
investors is by showing how profitable
you are as a business one of the
expenses that works against your income
on the tax return is depreciation so if
you choose to altar depreciation whether
you choose to increase it or decrease it
that can determine how profitable your
business is and can determine whether or
not an investor wants to invest inside
of your company hmm
what if we just arbitrarily changed that
eight-year number to something higher
maybe 10 years all of a sudden just from
this one simple change instead of
showing a giant 37 500 expense every
year we would only have to show a thirty
thousand dollar expense every year now
this may not seem like much but remember
Waste Management today has over 32 000
trash trucks just this one little
sleight of hand means that we just made
our company
240 million dollars more profitable if
that doesn't pump up the stock price and
get you a bonus I don't know what will
this is the beauty of cooking the books
one simple little change an 8 to a ten
for their front loader trash trucks or
10 years to 12 years for their other
trucks and suddenly show around a
quarter of a billion dollars more in
profit and just to clarify so when you
depreciate something this is like
required by the government right
required by the IRS so if you like fudge
the numbers are changed like the useful
life or like how many years have been
appreciated by that is illegal right
this Rod yes so if you're choosing to
alter the depreciation schedule by not
following the depreciation rules then
you are committing a form of tax fraud
and so depreciation has taken over the
course of the period of time that the
government has chosen if you start
establishing your own periods and your
own metrics you can definitely find
yourself in some tax trouble this is our
friend Carlton Dennis by the way yeah so
how's it going everybody my name is
Carlton Dennis licensed enrolled agent
and I help everyday entrepreneurs
leverage the tax code to the fullest
extent he really helped us understand
how Waste Management cooked the books
and if you want to save on taxes legally
you should definitely subscribe to his
Channel with the link below he's got
some of the best tax content on YouTube
and this trick that he helped us explain
this is just the beginning so don't go
anywhere yet because we're just getting
started
[Music]
another big expense in the trash
business is landfills landfills are
expensive and waste management owned and
operated more than 100 of them at the
time and just like trash trucks as trash
trucks get used their value goes down so
you have to account for that expense
which drives down your profit the same
goes for landfills as your landfills get
filled with trash they go down in value
so you too have to record those expenses
as your landfills fill up which again
drives down your profit landfill
expenses are a very Niche thing that not
many people will notice it's as simple
as not recording these landfill related
expenses at all no one will bat an eye
again make you look more profitable on
paper than you really are
and then there were the so-called sweeps
[Music]
so far we've only cooked the books to
reduce our expenses how much money we're
spending on paper but there's another
lever we can tweak Revenue how much
money we're making on paper and to make
us look like we're making more money on
paper we're gonna do something called a
sweep at the end of every quarter take a
sweep of all the stuff your company has
look for cash that has been set aside
for reserves reserves are cash that has
been set aside for things like
emergencies accidents payroll for
workers money needed to keep the
day-to-day operations going
and then it's simple instead of leaving
that money market as reserves just
arbitrarily mark it as income and call
it a day thereby making it look like the
company was bringing in more money than
it really was
these are only a few of the things Waste
Management's executive team did to cook
the books
there were many other tactics but they
all revolved around this same concept
move a few numbers around here and there
to show that the company is doing better
than it is thus pumping the stock price
thus pumping your wallet however if all
you did was cook the books you would be
immediately screwed because
unfortunately for you public companies
get audited meaning that it's required
by law that an independent accounting
company looks at your books to make sure
there aren't any discrepancies like
these that is a problem accountants are
trained to look for inaccuracies like
these so we gotta find a way around this
and in this case it was an accounting
firm called Arthur Anderson
[Music]
Arthur Anderson was one of the biggest
accounting companies in the world and
they specialized in auditing so it
didn't take them long to know that
something wasn't adding up but even when
they came to you accusing you of fraud
you were sure of one thing everyone has
a price all you had to do was find
theirs once you did it was as easy as
wiring Arthur Anderson additional fees
to look the other way and just like that
you had the one organization that was
supposed to keep you in check eating out
of your pocket waste management was now
knee-deep in white collar crime and the
problem with cooking your books is that
it comes a vicious cycle every year you
would have to beat last year's inflated
numbers unless you wanted the stock
price to go down
and the only way to do that was to cook
the books even more so every year you
would have to fake reports based on the
fake reports of last year it was fraud
on top of fraud on top of even more
fraud
but you didn't care as long as you kept
cooking the books Waste Management
stayed a success and the money kept
flowing in
in early 1992 the stock was at about 17
six years later it was at a staggering
55 dollars quite a phenomenal rise for a
company that collects trash
in those six years you didn't come up
with any cool inventions you didn't make
any big improvements on your services
and many people were actually
complaining about your incompetence like
when the garbage men simply drove by
people's houses without collecting the
trash or leaving half of it in the
driveway but all of this negativity
never showed in the stock price and it
was only a matter of time before people
started noticing these inconsistencies
thank you
by 1996 Dean Buntrock the CEO that
orchestrated this scheme had chosen to
retire at age 65. over the last 40 years
he had taken Waste Management from a
tiny one million dollar company to an
insane 9 billion dollar Behemoth
becoming the biggest Waste Services
Company in North America and now it was
time to enjoy his wealth and Legacy and
peace but trouble was on the horizon
Waste Management's new CEO arrived on
the scene to replace him and right from
the start the new CEO knew something
wasn't quite right with the company's
Financial reports
he ordered a review of the company's
accounting books what he found X eded
even his wildest suspicions
in just six years Dean and his
Executives had cooked the books by a
staggering 1.7 billion dollars that's
1.7 billion dollars more profit than
they actually made it was the biggest
Financial restatement in corporate
history when the news broke the stock
price immediately crashed taking 6
billion dollars with it from everyone
that was invested in the company we're
talking mutual funds Pension funds
individual investors and retirement
accounts of average everyday people but
Dean and the other Waste Management
Executives didn't care
Dean had already cashed in big time he
pocketed more than 16.9 million dollars
in bonuses over the years all thanks to
the incredible performance of his
company these millions came in the form
of performance bonuses and stock options
they got to hang on to their high-paying
prestigious jobs they got retirement
bonuses lucrative employment contracts
they dumped their shares onto the public
while the fraud was ongoing
the best part in the Years leading up to
the Scandal Dean knew they would
eventually get caught so right before
the news broke he sold 4.5 million
dollars worth of company stocks and
donated a bunch of Waste Management
stock to the college he went to to fund
a building in his name right before the
stock price crashed
pretty genius if you ask me
in the end the SEC ordered Dean to pay
almost 20 million dollars in fines and
his Executives got fined according to
how much money they made off with
Arthur Anderson they had to pay seven
million dollars for covering up the
fraud Arthur Anderson was also the
Auditors behind the Enron and Worldcom
collapses which put them out of business
Dean's Executives four of them ended up
settling the case with the SEC for 30.8
million dollars
[Music]
it's done oh good hey all right that's
it it's over you can all go to companies
gone what's sad about all of this is
that it was for just a measly 17 million
dollars and then he had to pay a 20
million dollar fine when in reality if
Dean had just not taken the company
public if he didn't have this grow at
all cost mentality if he just kept more
ownership of waste management and ran
the company leaner and more efficiently
he probably would have made more than 17
million dollars in legitimate money
because after all people will always
need their trash picked up and unless
you do a horrible job at it customers
aren't likely to ever switch trash
collectors he wouldn't have had to deal
with all the headaches of being a public
company he wouldn't have had to deal
with the board of directors pressure
from analysts and most importantly he
would have kept more of the money for
himself but instead he became the center
of quote one of the most egregious
accounting fraud
the SEC has ever seen end quote
Waste Management's Executives did a
fantastic job at hiding their fraudulent
schemes for almost six years but they
weren't the only company hiding a dark
secret it turned out that Victoria's
Secret was also hiding a dark secret the
owner of the lingerie brand Les Wexner
happened to be best friends with
everyone's favorite Private Island owner
every jepstein the owner of a company
that employs underaged girls to model in
lingerie being best friends with every
Epstein what could go wrong as it turns
out Les Wexner who could be a tyrant of
a boss gave Epstein unprecedented access
to his Empire
some point Epstein even boasted he was
the Personnel director for Victoria's
Secret which was probably the perfect
excuse to recruit more underaged girls
for his secret operation
the talking about all the details of
Epstein's connection to Victoria's
Secret would definitely get any public
video demonetized on YouTube which is
why we've released a private documentary
available only to members of this
Channel and so far people have been
loving the documentary all you have to
do to get access to the video on the
Epstein Victoria's Secret connection is
to click the join button below once you
sign up you'll get exclusive access to
documentaries on CIA black sites MK
Ultra the bin Laden papers and many more
these are the things they should be
teaching you in University about how the
world works but unlike University you
get all of this for just five dollars a
month and there's a refund policy too
unlike most YouTube memberships so if
you join and you don't it's worth it
email us within your first month of
joining and we will personally refund
you for your first month
after your first month there is no
refund
so scroll down and hit that join button
now
what's up guys we're sharing a mic right
now this is my friend Carlton and he
really helped me understand all the
stuff for this video so really big shout
out to him and Carlton you want to
introduce yourself hey guys my name is
Carlton Dennis I'm a licensed enrolled
agent and I'm a tax strategist so I help
out business owners reduce their overall
tax bill if you have any questions in
regards to taxes feel free to hit the
Subscribe link on my channel so yeah
call to mix on the best tax content on
YouTube so if you're a business owner or
self-employed or whatever and you want
to reduce your taxes legally definitely
check out his Channel with the link
below is super informative but yeah if
you guys are new here this is one of the
biggest channels on YouTube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime just like this video so if you
enjoyed this one click the Subscribe
button below you follow me on Instagram
at Jake's fan you can follow Carlton at
Carlton Dennis I believe but yeah that's
gonna wrap it up thanks for watching
stay dangerous out there and we will see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]